oh you know those Graphics they are
among my favorite because we are
continuing our new series vladi to Daddy
[Laughter]
we're gonna help our own Vlad you today
prepare for fatherhood it's right around
the corner and today we are highlighting
books for people actually we have
children of all ages whether you are an
expecting parent or couple whether
you've got teens going off to college
we've got something for you uh and a
couple of the books we're about to talk
about are published by Simon Schuster
which like CBS News is the division of
Paramount Global but a lot of these
books are not as well in Amazon books
editorial director Sarah gellman joins
us now for more on all of it uh Vlad is
here as well to soak in the knowledge
I'm ready for it I feel a lot of
responsibility right now the
expectations are very oh my gosh I hope
I don't mess up your child we learn you
cannot mess up your child I believe
that's a good we'll get to that and
we'll get to that okay so Sarah book one
is called good inside uh and it's by
kind of an Instagram famous parenting
Guru right so this is Dr Becky Kennedy
or Dr Becky as her followers call her
and she really Rose to fame during the
pandemic she has 1.5 million follow us
on Instagram now and she believes that
parents and children are good inside and
it's really this look at how she wants
us to stop correcting our kids and
instead really connect with them and she
takes very specific examples things like
problem behaviors like sleep or whining
and sibling rivalry and gives examples
for those I will say that I started
reading this book I used some of the
tips with my kids and they worked so
that gets my stamp of approval wow yeah
so but like when you say not correcting
children I mean it's good manners to
keep your elbows off the
tablet you don't like flick the elbow
anymore
a different way I think our parents are
maybe a little more focused on yeah yeah
lad has a dark childhood Sarah just to
prepare you for that fact like the talk
about that little pencil like I told you
yes don't embarrass me in this story
that's right it actually hurts exactly I
had a thing the other day with favorite
daughter Kirby and her son is 14 months
and I said no Luca no and she said we
don't
but anyway I actually feel like good
inside is a book that I would maybe give
to my family to my parents because it
seems very gentle and you want people to
understand what you're doing there's
actually a reason behind it uh the the
other book we can't actually even show
you the cover of the title because it's
got some profanity in it yes but and so
we can only say the title it is you
can't f up your kids by living powers
and Lindsay you like this why I love
this book so Lindsay's actually an
editor on my team yes it's very
provocative yes but before she joined my
team she wrote this book and she was the
guru behind this no shame parenting
Revolution and she's like you know you
have that friend who you want to take on
vacation because they do all the
research for you and you just show up
yes Lindsay's like that friend but for a
parent okay yeah okay so she believes
that we over stress way too much as
parents and that kids are resilient and
if you love them they're going to end up
okay and she takes on some pretty
controversial topics like drinking
during pregnancy she looks at screen
time she looks at the effects of divorce
on kids and I just feel like this book
gave me so much hope it's a great book
to give to someone who's pregnant she
has some very liberating advice on
pregnancy and childbirth okay I I
believe she's right about that and by
the way guys this is the the reason we
can't say the title that's the Federal
Communications
[Laughter]
act FCC anyway I know um so so you're a
mom of two boys I am this next book is
for parents of two to seven-year-olds
exactly so this is how how to talk so
little kids will listen and actually I
don't know the best seller how to talk
so kids will listen and listen so kids
will talk and one of the authors of this
book Joanna Faber is the daughter of the
original author of the best-selling wow
yeah so this is a book it just gave me a
lot of Hope as a parent that I could be
more patient and just a better parent
with my kids it takes specific
situations like going to the grocery
store with your little kids which can be
very challenging tells you how to deal
with that and my favorite thing about
this book is that it has an entire
chapter devoted to neurodivergent
children who have different needs than
non-neuro Divergent children so this
other book is focused on raising
independent kids and you say it reminds
you of 80 style parenting and we were
talking about that yeah 70s yeah stop
parenting grew up watching Gilligan's
Island and Star Trek and reruns because
we were at home I was a legend
like generation yes and you stayed out
and played and I'm Look at me now
Look at Us
is the author of this book and she
actually became Infamous when she wrote
in her New York Sun column that she let
her then nine-year-old son ride the New
York subway all by himself at age 20. he
was nine a mature nine Tony how do you
feel that's a little early I mean a
mature nine I don't know yeah it was
called the world's worst mom I remember
these articles there's a lot of black
chatter different now I don't think you
can I don't think that was that long ago
you don't but she believes that we we
just protect our kids too much and that
we should give them freedom to roam and
that that's better for them yeah she
says a thing that she thinks that
instead of baby proofing our world we
should World proof our baby and I loved
that I like that yeah When We Were Young
we used to go on a real deal adventures
all day long really my parents really
didn't care we didn't know where you
were
you were gone I didn't even notice you
were out of the house Sarah Gilman thank
you so much